PRF ,
BENJIN NETANYAHU.
HUNDERSTAND THE COST OF HIS KIK
OF THI?
>> FT CALLIT AE IR, BUT I WOULD
CALL IT A QUESTION OF IN.NA H
SHE
THE RUSSN ELI AIFORC LITERALLY Y
I WAS COMMITTED TONT
THER
L,IDN'T H WITH THE R AIRCEATOVI
INK WA
SO I MADFORT
ORTHE --
PUE RUSSIAMILITAE SOIE'T BUM EHI
ARCONCERNED, I
G OF CIVILIANS IN INULSPIRAL OUS
U FACE AER ISSUE
AND THAT IS IT COULD SPIRA TWH
TACTIC- E OFTICAL
I DON'T THK LLERS IFT'CTC.S NO
REFOR  YEARSK ITRE FIRD
PRUDENSTENING, BSETHE TODAY INKS
NOT PREVENTED.
>> I WAS IN KYIV A MONTH D TONS
TH THERE.
AND ONE THEMH ARLY W DIISRAEL.NO
.PORTED THE T
THEY HAVE ASKED AEL HAS TH
DEE.SKED FOR SOME
THAT
MAINTAINED A KIND OF --
OW O--EES ALLY SUPPORT THEM IN
LITR
THINKUL I THINK ISRAEL HAS SUP
OF
HUMANITARIANMS TAKEN IN ANE AMNW
ES
HUMANITA SEET  DECIO THET RAGOVE